books represent
an attempt
to permanently hold on to information
thoughts and stories
that's assuming you have um any
intention to actually hold on to what's
inside of them
not everybody does
[Music]
hello there folks tomorrow is the
beginning of banned books week and if
you've heard of it at all odds are you
know it best as that time when your
local library or bookstore sets up a
little display with a bunch of books
saying banned books weekend offers up
books that have at some point been
banned and if you've ever actually taken
a look at one of those displays you may
have found yourself scratching your head
at some of the things included there I
want to take this opportunity to talk
about something that has been on my mind
a bit lately and actually on other
people's minds as well off and on
be nice to see it on their minds more
consistently but that is the increasing
number of book challenges that have been
going on in America in libraries and
especially in schools now just for
clarification of language the difference
between a book ban and a book challenge
is the challenge is the beginning of the
Banning process where somebody
challenges the presence of a book in a
certain location be it a college a high
school a grade school the school library
the school curriculum or the public
library now not every book that is
challenged is ultimately banned although
any book that is banned it started as a
challenge now even though this is called
banned books week what I'm actually
going to be talking about are book
challenges my reason for doing that has
to do with the way that data is
correlated by the American Library
Association what they track year over
year are book challenges it might be
possible to actually find out how many
of these challenges actually went
through and became full bands but that
data is not collected in the same way
and would be much much much harder for
me to find and you know be able to parse
this however is available data and I
have to thank my partner Liz who is a
school librarian for helping point me to
the resources that I need to be able to
talk about this
now if you're wondering why I want to
talk about this well
some of you might remember that there
has intimately been a little bit of an
uproar over certain books being
challenged or banned the most notorious
recent example is probably the Banning
of the graphic novel Mouse by a
Tennessee school board Mouse is a
incredibly renowned celebrated story
about the Holocaust and it was removed
for containing quote unquote nudity
that's Mouse
nudity
and uh that sort of back door way of
trying to ban something that does have
business being available we'll get into
that
but this is kind of what I want to talk
about
a lot of the conservative movement
especially the far right have decided to
make libraries especially School
libraries Battlegrounds and the number
of challenges has spiked the nature of
the challenges has gotten uncomfortable
at times within the last few years and
this is also why you see targeting of
things like drag queen Story Hour being
held at local libraries
libraries are frequently a Battleground
in anything that could be considered a
culture War that's not a term I usually
like to use but I do feel it is
appropriate
when a group is attempting to remove the
availability of information they don't
like they are engaging in a war against
the culture
and demanding that it be what they want
it to be
so the data that I'm going to be using
and citing across this again comes from
the American libraries Association and
they have done detailed breakdowns year
over year for quite a while those
started in 2015.
I do have data going further back than
that and I'll cite some of that earlier
on but the really detailed information
or at least that was collected in a way
that was much more parsable for me that
starts in 2015. so what this will mostly
be looking at is the trends and how
things have changed from 2015 to 2021 uh
it stops 2021 because that is the most
recent year fully collected nothing
that's gone on in 2022 is going to be
part of this data set because they won't
collect it until we are into the next
year so that is going to be the range of
time that I'm primarily going to be
focused on I'm going to be looking at
what has changed in terms of what books
are getting challenged on what basis are
they getting challenged who is
challenging them and in what
institutions because if you look at the
data and see how things have shifted
there's some interesting and troubling
trends that emerge now before I start
really digging into numbers it's worth
just kind of breaking down the nature of
a challenge this is when someone and the
people involved are also part of the
data set whether it be a patron which
usually refers to someone who is
patronizing a local library a parent
which means it's somewhere involved in a
school it could either be part of the
curriculum or it could just be available
in the library or other outside forces
or students even uh these people will
say we don't believe that this book
should be available at this location
again whether it's the school the
library wherever they are making the
objection
that will then be looked into a book
challenge is made and it is then
considered whether or not it will be
removed from the shelves
the reasons for a book challenge are not
set in stone this is not a legal
proceeding where there are certain
specific things that you have to be able
to prove that it is this or that the
exact criteria that will get something
removed varies wildly from location to
location and so what you will find is
that in some areas you will see
citations of things like anti-family or
anti-authority or even things like
Satanism and the Occult which may not
turn up at all in other locations where
those sorts of things are not considered
to be concerns of the local populace so
I will be talking about uh amongst other
things some of the most cited reasons
for a challenge and the kinds of books
that can be challenged literally
anything literally anything can be
challenged nothing is immune and that
runs the entire gamut from resource
books to children's books whether it is
a sweet and adorable Illustrated story
about two male Penguins raising a chick
based on real events or whether it's 50
Shades of freaking Gray
anything
can be challenged and potentially banned
so with that in mind
let's start looking at some numbers when
examining older data it's basically
lumped together as 1990 to 1999 and 2000
to 2009 and there wasn't a great deal of
significant shift from one decade to the
other in terms of who was making the
challenges or why there were a couple of
shifts in terms of an increase in the
number of challenges made by other
initiators and on the basis of quote
unquote other objections but that mostly
has to do with a failure to fully
categorize this older data so a lot of
stuff just kind of gets lumped under
other starting in 2001 we start getting
the list of the top 10 most challenged
books in the country which is going to
be a fairly big part of what I'm talking
about here now I'm not going to go over
what every top 10 was for all those
years but I will be citing some specific
instances as I feel it emphasizes or
illustrates something that I feel is
important now it's worth noting that
from 2014 to 2020 the most challenged
Institute institution is the public
library from year to year the percentage
of challenges that happen there can run
anywhere from 38 to 66 percent but all
of those years from 2014 to 2020 that is
the category with the most challenges no
matter how low or high the percentage is
it's a bigger percentage than all the
others however 2021 saw something
different it became the first year where
the most challenges took place in the
school libraries and for the record it
was 44 to public libraries 37 so it
wasn't even particularly close there was
another shift that happened before that
in that starting in 2018
more bands began to happen in school
libraries as opposed to over School
curriculum now this is an important
shift because it marks a distinct change
in attitude in the people who are
attempting to get these Books banned and
removed what I mean by that is prior to
2018 in terms of the years that we have
good data for
the most common thing in relation to
schools the challenge is the actual
School curriculum books that children or
teenagers were assigned to read meaning
these these books were literally put in
children's Hands by teachers and parents
for whatever reason Justified or not
went oh wait a minute wait a minute and
for a long time that happened more often
than just trying to ban it out of the
school library but in 2018 that shifted
what that means in terms of a difference
in mentality is it went from I don't
want my child to be required to read
this
to a higher degree of emphasis on the
idea of I don't want this available to
my child at all that's an important
change because objecting to Something in
the curriculum it can be not over the
simple existence of that book but simply
because you don't feel that something
that should be required but since 2018
shouldn't be there at all has become the
prevailing attitude it is worth noting
that 2020 is the one exception year in
terms of there being more Library bans
than curricular bands but like 2020 the
data for that year wow accurate is wonky
and out of place because of covid
because so many of these institutions
were closed it as I'll mention later it
had by far fewer uh book challenges than
it happened in really any of the year
since 2010 and the data is off and weird
because a lot of libraries were closed a
lot of schools were closed so it's data
that is not consistent with every other
year already that doesn't mean that data
from 2020 is not helpful in some other
ways because for example when I was
looking at the reasons cited and what
the more common reasons were or what
some new ones were that appeared that
hadn't showed up before 2020 was where
we started seeing books challenged
because of black lives lives matter or
being anti-racist
I will say that again books in 2020
began being challenged for being
anti
racist that's not an interpretation you
need to understand that when the Ala
assembles this data they are lumping
things together but they are lumping it
under the descriptions given by the
people challenging them because they do
have to offer like what is your general
categorization and as I'll get into with
some of these some of these are very
blatantly just trying to ban things that
they don't like that most people would
think that's
is that a bad thing to have
such is the case with anti-racism and if
you think this is just a matter of what
the aala is making some kind of
editorializing there they took these
arguments of these patrons or these
parents and are saying that they didn't
want something because it was
anti-racist the parents probably didn't
say that well given some of the language
that appears in other years such as in
2021 woke
making a notable dent in the number of
challenges that were based on it I don't
think the Ala decides to lump things
under woke that would have been a word
that the parents or the patrons chose to
use now I doubt anyone's going to be
particularly surprised by the fact that
I am going to put a focus and Spotlight
onto books challenge for containing
lgbtqia plus content
queer content
so yeah that has been going on a lot but
it's also been going on a lot for a
while in years prior to 2017 pretty much
everything got lumped under other
categories there was a section for
homosexuality and it's possible that
transgender related things or any gender
related things were lumped under that or
possibly under another category now
starting in 2016 homosexuality no longer
appears by itself it got lumped under
lgbtq later to become lgbtqia plus
because yes they acknowledge there are
other letters involved in that but then
starting in 2017 it became the number
one reason for book challenges and it
remained so ever since until 2021 where
sexually explicit surpassed it now
centrally explicit is a category that's
basically always been there and it's a
basis that most parents would at least
understand well you know that might be a
concern turn what's the context how
explicit what age
so there is a reason to certainly have
the sexually explicit content as a basis
for a challenge and as I said it's
always been there
but I think it's really important to
understand
why in 2021 it overtook lgbtqia Plus
because it's not because more sexually
explicit material became available in
these locations it's because virtually
every book that was challenged because
it contained queer content was also
challenged as being sexually explicit
this has been part of the targeted
tactic of the far right for the last few
years and it really ramped up in 2021
there is a reason that groomer has
become a go-to term that the far right
will use for anybody standing up for any
queer rights especially the rights of
trans people it is because they want the
idea of sexually explicit and sexually
predatory to be linked implicitly and
always with queerness so the reason
sexually explicit became the number one
in 2021 is because it appeared on nearly
every single challenge done one to a
queer book and then there would also be
some books challenged for sexually
explicit content that didn't have queer
material
so it grows higher because it was
pulling double duty now and let me show
my homework a little bit on this because
in 2021 looking at the top 10 most
challenged books from that year every
single one of them that contains some
kind of queer content is challenged not
only for containing that but for also
being sexually explicit The Only
Exception is the book this book is gay
by Juno Dawson that one is actually a
sexual education book and so instead of
being marked as sexually explicit
because it's in an educational context
it instead got challenged on the basis
of being sexual education I'll repeat
that the basis for a challenge
was that it was educational
another thing to note about queer books
since lgbtqia Plus or any of its
variants that might have been a little
bit shorter uh was put in as a category
that has accounted for the number one
most challenged book of the year every
year since that term became a category
with only one exception that exception
being 2017. and the reason for that was
because of 13 Reasons Why now 13 Reasons
Why actually came out back in 2007 and
it was number three of the talk ban
books in 2012 but it hadn't been on the
list since then but the Netflix
adaptation brought attention back to it
so for depicting suicide that shot it to
the top of the list where normally queer
content has been easily unchallenged and
the main reason queer books lost the top
spot there was because of a literal
cultural phenomenon now I said that
since being introduced lgbtqia plus
books have easily made the top spot and
a large amount of the categories and
since being introduced it has accounted
for no fewer than four books out of the
top ten and it has gone as high as eight
books in the top ten that was in 2019.
but even on its lower end years for that
category to show up in a minimum 40
percent of the top ten
that's pretty solid representation why
don't we contrast that real quickly for
how frequently homosexuality came up as
a category before they were using
lgbtqia plus from 2000 to 2009
homosexuality only made up seven and a
half percent of all challenges
now keep in mind since being introduced
lgbtqia plus was the number one basis of
a challenge every year except for 2021
homosexuality was seven and a half
percent
for a decade so getting into years I
have a little bit more data on going
from 2010 through 2016 which was when
lgbtqia plus first got introduced and
remember it started being the number one
reason in 2017 homosexuality or books
being banned on the basis of
homosexuality ranged everywhere from
zero in the top ten to three
so as recently as 2011 we had years
where none of the books in the top 10
were being banned on the basis of
portraying homosexuality but then once
we have lgbtqia plus year after it first
starts showing up as a cited reason it's
number one until sexually explicit now I
mentioned earlier that 2019 was the year
with the most of the top 10 being books
with queer content eight out of ten the
two that had no queer content for the
record were the handmaid's tale again
kind of brought to prominence again due
to the uh creation of a show a bit of a
cultural movement and the Harry Potter
series for some reason I had to try and
think about why that would have been
because understand while it is fairly
well known at this point that Harry
Potter was challenged or banned
especially early into its popularity for
depicting the occult and magic and
Satanism and all this utter nonsense
sense for as absolutely zero respect as
I have for JK Rowling at this point like
those challenges were absurd but Harry
Potter made the top 10 again in 2019
that's after a 16-year Hiatus last time
it made the top 10 was 2003.
what is going on there
well
at a guess it's actually a possibly
unintended side effect of the increased
focus on queer books because
when you collect and energize and
encourage a population that flatly does
not want queer content made available in
any way shape or form to well anybody
but especially anybody still in school
you are going to have a higher
percentage amongst that group of people
who also object to Harry Potter most
likely for religious reasons so I think
the fact that Harry Potter showed up
again is a side effect of the
concentrated effort to energize and
encourage more book challenges
especially on queer topics
because amongst the people who are going
to do that you're going to get more
people who have issues with Harry Potter
so with that in mind it actually is not
surprising that the year with the most
queer books in the top 10 also saw the
return of Harry Potter now I'd said
before that from 2017 to 2021 there was
no less than four books in the top ten
with queer content there actually was
one exception but that was 2020 which
again was wonky for reasons I already
mentioned but there's another reason why
there was slightly less the thing is
2020 as I mentioned before saw the
increased attention to books depicting
issues of race and what I mean by that
is depicting the perspective of people
of color
at all so that year saw the Banning of
things like the hate U give something
happened in our town All American boys
and stamped racism anti-racism and you
all of these were challenged on the
basis of being anti-police or
anti-racist and if you think the fact
that the black lives matter movement
kicked off then is somehow a coincidence
well one of those books all-American
boys had uh an interesting specific
challenge in at least one instance which
was that it was quote too much of a
sensitive matter right now the moment in
time
when the most attention is being drawn
to the problems
of specifically police violence against
black people
is not the time to talk about
issues of
societal or police violence towards
black people and you may have already
noticed that with stamped there's an
interesting one that it was a challenge
because it did not discuss racism
against all people which is the book
challenge equivalent of all lives matter
yeah
okay now even though 2020's top 10 was
heavily dominated by racial issues the
number one most challenged book was
still an lgbtqia plus book stick a pin
in that specific one I'm gonna come back
to it later but while we're on the topic
of racially charged reasons to ban
something I want to take a look
specifically at the book The hate U give
and more specifically I want to take a
look at the reasons cited for it being
challenged because there's a shift in
language on that one now the hate U give
is illustrative and helpful because it's
been in the top 10 most man books for
four out of the last five years that we
have data on between 2017 and 2021 and
so I'll explain what the basis for the
challenge was initially when it was
first challenged in 2017 and then how
that language changed in 2017 it was
challenged on the basis of being vulgar
depicting drug use and containing
profanity in 2018 it was challenged for
being anti-comp when which would remain
when it was in the top 10 again in 2020
and then in 2021 it still has those
other things I've cited but it has now
added indoctrination of a social agenda
the use of that language and the fact
that woke appeared in 2021 really gives
the game away of who is pushing
for these challenges because this
language specifically has been either
manufactured or reappropriated and then
pushed very hard and in a very unified
way
by far-right media
politicians and activists nothing was
challenged on the basis of being
indoctrination into a social agenda any
year prior to 2021 it would have had no
reason to be
but these are the buzzwords these are
the buzzwords drilled into the ground
level supporters who are being egged on
and encouraged to go and forcibly remove
books from libraries and schools and it
is getting worse from 2001 to 2014 the
number of challenges per year now this
is a number of books challenge but
number of challenges because sometimes
you can challenge multiple books at a go
so the number of challenges during that
stretch 2001 to 2014 it ranged from 311
to a high of 547. now that was in 2004.
2006 was very close behind it was
actually only behind by one uh for the
most but that was the range 311 to 547.
2015 actually saw it dip below 300 total
challenges for the first time this
Millennium and then it ranged from 323
to 377 from 2016 to 2019. now this is
generally trending
downwards we're seeing fewer the highs
in the previous stretch up in the 500s
we're not hitting those now
things seem to have calmed down now does
that mean Society was more accepting not
necessarily more likely a lot of schools
or libraries were preemptively removing
things that they thought might have been
challenged or simply weren't ever
putting it on the shelves in the first
place simply to avoid the hassle of
having to deal with this stuff can I
prove that that's the case no but if I
were to guess that was at least
partially responsible for things going
down fewer things to object to now 2020
only saw 156 challenges but again we've
talked about why 2020 the data is
actually super unhelpful because of how
many of these institutions weren't even
open
but then 2021
it came roaring back
729 challenges in 2021 and from what
that I could find it's not official yet
and it won't be till next year but from
what Dad I could find 2022 was on Pace
to all well already have beaten that
and to probably leave it completely in
the dust the scale and the scope of the
problem should already be evident based
on 2021. when we get 2022's data I
expect it's going to become
incredibly clear
that this is a chosen Battleground
so I said there was a book I wanted to
highlight now that book is Melissa now
Melissa originally published as George
it has since been retitled since George
is actually the main character's dead
name and eventually the author uh was
convinced that maybe that shouldn't be
the title of the book I mean the story
deals with the character's transition
over time so it's not like the name
shouldn't appear in the book maybe it
shouldn't be the title though but in any
case Melissa first made the top 10 list
of most challenged books in 2016. it's
been in the top 10 every year since then
and it's been number one in 2018 2019
and 2020. this is the story of a young
trans girl
it humanizes her it gives the reader
reasons to empathize and understand her
and it has never stopped being among the
most challenged and a three-year stretch
as the most challenged that's pretty
impressive
part of the reason I want to highlight
this book though is this was a book that
my partner Liz again a school librarian
she had to deal with the challenge to
its presence in the library
and I feel it is illustrative now I
mentioned before that lgbtqia plus
became a very top category but that's
nationally
the feeling towards that kind of thing
will vary from Community to communities
from state to state
I live in Vermont Vermont is a fairly
Progressive state in most areas
and as a result
it wasn't challenged simply for
depicting lgbtqia plus characters
because honestly that wouldn't fly here
it would other places obviously it is
used as a basis of a challenge often
enough to show up as such a high ranked
reason but
because of the nature of how things are
around here
and the generally tolerant
attitude towards most queer populations
in most parts of this state
instead the parents who challenged this
book
tried to challenge it
as being sexually explicit or actually
I'm sorry their words were that it was
pornographic
so they claimed
that because in this non-illustrated
book at one point a character comes into
possession
of an adult magazine like a Playboy
effectively
that that makes the book
pornographic for acknowledging the
existence of these magazines
uh that challenge did not succeed for
the record but it was something that Liz
had to go through
and that tactic was chosen for the same
reason that nudity was used as a reason
to remove Mouse
if you don't live in an area where it
will be allowed to go through to ban it
for the reason you actually don't like
it
because it addresses the Holocaust
because it depicts a trans character in
a sympathetic light
well then you find another reason
this is the library equivalent of when
you work a job
there are a ton of reasons why your
employer is not allowed to fire you tons
of basis is by which they can't fire
they can't fire you for your religious
beliefs they can't fire you for your
race they can't fire you for your sex
but
the thing is
they can find a reason to get rid of you
that will be allowed
so
not that I'm trying to throw myself on
the cross but I got laid off from my
last day job in 2020. now the official
reason was they were doing layoffs due
to covet
makes sense
I found out later that uh the only
people laid off were me and one other
person
that being a long suspected absolutely
redundant position in the design
Department
so despite
the entire company
you know dealing with covid and it
crunching on the amount of sales we
could get on what could be produced tons
of areas where you would think they
would have to make Cuts because remember
I worked for a company that not only had
a sales force a marketing force it had a
production force a lot of whom could not
come in or could only come in under very
restricted conditions because of six
feet rules to come in and actually
produce the stuff that was being sold
you'd think some of those people would
go
no
no just me and one other person
now I can't prove that they let me go
because of my gender expression and in
the state that I worked uh your gender
and your gender expression was a
protected category but
um
they can't let me go for that but they
found another reason and I can't prove
that that was really why they let me go
but I was presenting more and more and
more as myself uh prior to the lockdown
and
I've been incredibly close to some
people who have worked in HR
I know for a fact
that they will be careful about not
firing people because of reasons they're
not allowed to
but if the reason that a company wants
to get rid of somebody is something not
allowed
they'll find a quote-unquote legitimate
reason
same thing here
if you live in an area where Banning a
trans-positive book for being a
transpositive book isn't going to fly
or Banning a holocaust related book
for being a holocaust related book won't
fly
find another reason find a technicality
and this is also in keeping with as I
said before the deliberate connecting
of queerness to sexual explicitness
to pornography to predation a couple of
other little bits of data to keep in
mind exactly who was initiating the most
challenges generally went back and forth
from year to year between either parents
or patrons as I said in the case of
schools it's gonna be parents and if
there are more challenges in a public
library it's going to be patrons
but um you know what's an incredibly
small percent
students
students don't think these books
shouldn't be there
there was only one year where it was
anything higher than one percent and the
highest it ever got was three
students don't feel like they need to be
protected from this
it's parents and it's patrons
community members
people who increasingly
over 700 times in 2021
are acting very much deliberately
with a clear political motivation
now I'm not saying that you can't have
your politics guide your actions that
you can't act on your beliefs
but this isn't just people deciding
independently on their own
I'm concerned
I don't think that book should be there
this is a coordinated offensive this is
right-wing figures
helling the people who listen to them go
out and demand these books be removed
and we know that people are listening
because in the challenges we see the
same nonsense language
about social agenda
and being woke
that you hear from these people
this is not an organic Grassroots
movement this is manufactured and it's
going to keep getting worse libraries
repositories of information
that people
like the far right don't like
are always early targets I mentioned
that drag queen story hours are being
targeted for harassment for threats
whether it be protests outside the
building or people literally marching
into libraries with guns to protect
children
from drag queens
people that as far as children are
concerned are just really pretty people
in shiny ball gowns with High hair
Librarians are being threatened simply
for putting up lgbtqi plus displays and
multiple drag queen story times have
been canceled due to threats of violence
that is not independent
of the rise of challenges that is not
independent
from the fact that school libraries
overtook School curriculum that is not
independent of the fact that in 2021
School libraries shot past public
libraries as the institution with the
most challenged books
that is not independent of the fact that
number one has almost always been a
queer book and that queer books make up
such a high percentage consistently of
the books challenged and banned and that
ones that aren't those are very likely
in the last few years to be anything
addressing
Injustice or racial issues our
institutions of learning and knowledge
are under attack
because there's one other thing that
I'll add into this
you remember how I said there was the
shift from attacking the curriculum more
than the libraries to the libraries
going with a shift from saying I don't
think they should be required to read
that to I don't think they should have
access to that at all
there was a term that used to be among
the most common cited reasons for a
challenge that does not appear anymore
inappropriate for the age range now the
thing is depending on the book and
depending on the grade it's available to
that can be a pretty
Lively debate
there is argument to be had at what age
are kids able to read certain things at
what age should they
that doesn't show up anymore
and the reason it doesn't
is because it concedes the idea that
there is an appropriate age
maybe the age that has access to it
right now isn't appropriate therefore we
challenge it
but that implies that there is some age
that is appropriate now you do not see
that in the list of cited reasons at all
because they will not see that ground
anymore
they will not see the idea that anybody
should ever have access
to information
about racial Justice
and about queer people
not in fiction not in education
they want us to be made unacceptable
and it's hard to know
how to fight that
because you can't fight fire with fire
doing a bunch of book challenges to
conservative books
is not going to do anything to help
that's just leading to a situation where
nothing becomes available to anybody and
that's not helpful
so
what can be done
well there is often volunteer or
donations that can be made to your local
library or possibly your school's
library program
support these places
support their ability to fight these
challenges
support
knowledge support the existence
of knowledge the availability of
knowledge support librarians
and
we power through
and I fear that after banned books week
people won't be thinking about this
anymore
despite the fact that these challenges
go on
every day across the country
everywhere
find out what's happening locally
and find out what you can do to help
thank you very much for listening
if you want to support the content that
I make patreon is the best way to do it
it's what enables me to do this as my
living after I was laid off from that
job
so
if you are not able to support me that
way like share and subscribe
put the word out about what is going on
as best you can
I would appreciate it it would help this
it would help me
it would help people understand the
scope of the problem hopefully
But ultimately what I really really want
you to remember
is that you are beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you are the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
Council
is adjourned
[Music]
time to give my thanks to my highest
supporting patrons that would include
Robin Moore Zubin ludfula to rock the
thing that goes doink in the anime
Oliver B Linda Walters emu dalke the
oatha Boyd Becky Sparks pronabi likes
the poodle Zach eidolin Tracy Scrabble
angry Casper Adam RDL Taylor Shane Ross
Shayla gourlay Brendan Larose and TT
[Music]
if you want your name set while these
guys try and distract me
consider looking at the rewards on my
patreon
[Music]